[Music]
yo that gravy addison clip is crazy man
i feel really bad
for addison
yeah and it's not gravy's fault at all
no i just feel bad because like her
parents are just like constantly in the
[ __ ] news now they're trying to make
it about themselves and they are you
know yeah completely it's like just
parent i think what makes it weird is
that yeah her parents are clearly
going through something i'm sure
addison's sitting there like trying to
figure out her own career and her her
own like pr strategy and all this [ __ ]
and then she's like wait my [ __ ] mom
did what yeah my dad did what it's like
you guys are [ __ ] up my thing yeah
[ __ ] and where i eat i really gotta pee
can i just run and pee real fast you
gotta hold it for seven
i can't i've been holding it for 30.
well everyone it's just me again you
know how it goes at the end of these
little at the end of the bone zones when
cody has to squeeze his little [ __ ]
peacock to get his you know little honey
piss dribble out of his tiny little b
dick you know how that goes when he just
has to push his two ugly little fingers
together to get that little [ __ ]
that's what it sounds like when he's
just mushing his tiny tiny
and this is not me projecting myself
onto cody you know like this is not just
me repeatedly making the same joke about
cody when he goes take a pee because i'm
insecure or something because this is
the same process i go through every
morning i wake up and i'm full of piss
because i'm an athlete and i drink a lot
of water but then when i have to pee i
have to go just
mush my ugly little fingers together
over the toilet and i just giggle to
myself and go short king everyone loves
a short king
my dick sounds like it's farting because
i can barely get the piss out you know
just
[Applause]
short king
that's my life f1 is back this weekend
really exciting lewis had a you know a
spa was what a [ __ ] doo-doo race you
know it wasn't a doo-doo race it was
kind of a doodle race there's plenty of
action in the midfield but you know i
don't know spa is such a great track but
it always feels you always feel a little
bit let down for some reason i don't
know why spa always has a lot of what
could uh what it shoulda you know anyway
cody's back so no more racing talking
about racing again yeah they were just
you know having a having a having to
think with the ultimate racist
the plans you you're the ultimate racist
welcome back to the racist hour the most
racist podcast in the world that's what
we should do if we start an f1 pod the
network racist podcast in the world
we'll call it the racist hour we would
get no sponsors
literally no one would jump on board you
sent me um either jesus or marrow was
starting a it's uh
marrow yeah i was doing a f1 podcast on
amp i need mero to just let me on the
show one time dude you should you could
you could definitely get on that i'm
trying to you know i asked mazad to like
pitch me for it i'm just like bro come
on let me talk about race car oh for
sure
dude you know what some so interesting
to me when you think of race cars what
in your mind what is what wheels
uh smoke yeah no but i mean like what's
the vibe like what do you associated
with beds yeah race car beds there you
go i don't know speed and like like
like suits like the racing suits okay
i guess because i was i was thinking
about it and up until f1 kind of got
popular in the last like year or two two
years outside i think in america race
cars has kind of just seemed like a
redneck thing oh yeah for sure yeah
nascar and [ __ ] yeah sorry yeah yeah
before i knew about f1 it was that's
what it was to me yeah and i think
that's kind of still what it is in
people's minds like even they say oh
nascar fans be like look at this going
in circles you know yeah this kind of
stereotype it's just interesting because
in europe it's so prestigious and you
know has like all this history and [ __ ]
you know yeah i don't know i realize now
i'm like oh that's why no one [ __ ]
cares yeah
i mean people care they don't really
[ __ ] care now man there's oh they're
in the states yeah they're everywhere
yeah it's it's a shame too because i
watched some recent nascar and i don't
know what the programming is like how
they choose things but nascars on
regular tracks are so interesting
because that [ __ ] is just straight up
mario kart they hit the [ __ ] out of each
other yeah it's it's like acceptable in
nascar yes like someone will get like
shunted off in like a really shitty way
the announcers will go oh almond dinger
gets it his elbows wide on turn seven
sends smith into the dust yeah you're
gonna be coming back you'll be real
upset after that one and then they'll
cut to their radio and be like
[ __ ] push me off and you're like
this is exciting sorry i'm drunk yeah
yeah
yeah
oh is this a recent crash what's this
from just generally there's just crash
highlights yeah all the drivers holy
[ __ ]
that's insane
but i say it's a shame because
i feel
yeah god damn if they could bring back
it gets more and more morbid yeah start
exploding oh okay yeah that's morbid
yeah that's right holy
i feel if they could bring back the
older cars when they were scarier and
they're more death machines i think
people would be all about it now yeah
put like a turret yeah
yeah nah you know it's crazy okay last
racing thing i'll shut the [ __ ] up so on
helmets they have these things called
tear-offs it's like a sticker okay so if
like dirt gets on your visor you can
tear it off and throw it
it's looking someone this weekend in a
race through a tear off and threw it and
it got caught in like one of the top
drivers right now for ferrari it got
caught in his brake duct and it
overheated and
so it completely [ __ ] his car because
it was just like plastic burning on the
brakes and then in the process it fried
one of his sensors so then he like went
to go pit the car towards the end of the
race and he was one kph over the speed
limit and he got a penalty for it so he
lost the place at the end and it was all
because of that [ __ ] kids tear off oh
jesus yeah anyway
yeah